[Musique]
evelyne attend le métro soudain elle se
sent et aussi tout devient noir quand
elle ouvre les yeux
elle est allongée au sol entourés par
deux ambulanciers même si elle reprend
ses esprits et se sent mieux on lui
propose de l'emmener en ambulance à
l'hôpital à l'urgence on lui explique
qu'elle a eu un malaise vagal et on lui
donne son congé un mois plus tard elle
retombe dans les pommes
parce qu'on lui réclame 132 $ pour son
transport en ambulance
eh oui l'ambulance est un service qu'il
faut payer
par contre au québec et au nouveau
brunswick par exemple ceux qui ont des
assurances collectives pourraient être
remboursés en partie selon les provinces
certains n'ont pas à payer ambulance par
exemple au québec
si vous avez plus de 65 ans si vous êtes
victime d'un accident de la route ou du
travail ou encore si vous êtes membre de
la grc ou en prison
le fin mot de l'histoire votre santé n'a
pas de prix mais l'ambulance elle
oui